hello everyone and welcome to the
greatest playlist on youtube that does
sound like an exaggeration but uh i
always exaggerate on this channel so i i
thought i'd better just continue uh in
that direction uh at this time instead
of showing you a very nice game i'm
going to show you two incredible puzzles
uh it's from a book by george mihaly
which listed in uh it's a book in three
parts strategy and tactics and it's my
one of my favorite books
on chess altogether i remember a long
long time ago when i was still in
college i had this book and i was riding
uh the train uh and i would you know
solve puzzles but sometimes the puzzles
were so difficult that it would you know
the entire ride of the train was not
enough it was maybe 45 minutes to solve
the puzzle so it took me quite a lot to
you know get through the first book
maybe even over a year i only
solved them on the train i did not do
any uh work at home uh so it really took
me a while but these are really really
enjoyable and it's a different
type of type of puzzle than what occurs
for example in today's modern games
because players have really prepared
everything and you have a really really
perfect position basically that's been
approved by engines for both black and
white and then the positions that occur
that uh maybe some player makes a
mistake okay you can solve that but it's
uh probably not going to be as
instructive as these uh puzzles that i'm
going to show you so this is the first
one let's check it out and if you guys
have any questions i would uh you know
very happily answer them in the comments
uh but this is a puzzle by none other
than the great paul kerris uh and it's
white to mate in four so white only has
a king and a bishop and it really
shows you how to uh well just how to
think so you're going to enjoy this one
uh feel free to pause the video and try
and solve this while i give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations uh on finding it
if you found mate in five that's fine
but we really need a mating for that
that's the good stuff here and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
uh it is uh bishop the g5 but we're
gonna explain why it's bishop to g5 and
these uh positions like i said they're
gonna be really really awesome so if you
don't have time to solve them now just
print screen them or you know save them
for for later and then maybe try and try
and solve them it will really really uh
improve your thinking so here uh bishop
the g5 is the correct move but uh to
make
it seem believable let's try bishop to
d2 and we want to deliver bishop to c3
checkmate so black just plays the rook
to c7 and we can't play bishop to c3
checkmate and now if we go bishop to f4
we want to deliver bishop to e5
checkmate rook to c5 just prevents that
and now we don't really have anything if
bishop g5 going for this bishop to f6
move uh to deliver uh check now and then
just knight c6 and now after bishop to
f6 uh sorry about that uh delivering
check we have knight to the e5 blocking
check and now there is no more victory
so uh what you would have to do here is
go bishop to g5 like we said but okay
bishop to d2 doesn't work if you try
bishop to e3
i just work the d7 now there is no
checkmate the d4 square is covered by
the rook we could go bishop to f4 to go
for this but now knight to f7 and the
knight prevents it and also guards all
of these squares the rook covers this so
there's no way for us to deliver
checkmate
and the last thing you could try is
bishop to f4 to go for the immediate
bishop to e5 but now knight to f7 the
knight now covers e5 and after bishop e3
of course the rook blocks with rook to
d7 so if you've
thought about all of these moves then
you found solutions for black on how to
defend this and then you probably found
bishop to g5 as well now the point is to
prevent bishop to f6 checkmate you have
to
play a move with the rook so there's no
way for the knight to cover the uh the
f6 square we have to play rook to f7 and
this is exactly what we wanted because
now uh the rook is preventing the knight
from reaching f7 and we know that knight
to f7 was a very important defending
square
for black in this position so now we
play bishop to f4 threatening bishop to
e5 checkmate and now the knight can no
longer guard the e5 square from f7 so
the knight has to go to c6 to block the
e5 square and now only now we play
bishop to d2
and now bishop to c3 will be checkmate
and that's mating for because now first
the rook was in the way of the knight
from defending against mate now the
knight is in the way of the rogue
because now rook to c7 of course the
knight is in the way bishop to c3 is
just checkmate so that's uh
that's uh that's the idea just uh first
bishop g5 the knight has to uh block
this and oh the rook has to go to f7
block the knight then the knight blocks
the rook and that's how you deliver
checkmate in this position i don't know
the first time i saw this i was very
very impressed and i was very happy with
it and i was more than happy to share
this with my friends at the bar in the
library so maybe maybe you guys would
enjoy that as well so that's the first
one i wanted to show you a very nice
puzzle by paul kerres and now we go to
the second one also very enjoyable it's
more of an attacking one because both
players still have the bishop pair the
queens are on the board two rooks are on
the board but it's um
quite a beautiful attacking pattern that
uh it's a position that can occur in
your own game so maybe just knowing this
will make it a lot easier for you to try
and use it in your own games it's uh
from the 1951 tournament the players are
battered versus
[Music]
i could not find the whole game if i
could i would have shown the game in its
entirety so we're just going to show
this position now it's white to win uh
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the absolute uh strongest way for
white to to win this and the quickest
one of course while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding such a
wonderful continuation and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
bishop captures on h7 now i know you
guys probably thought about this but
some of you probably thought about
bishop to f6 as well so we're gonna
discuss bishop to f6 just briefly as we
are threatening mate in one the problem
is black can block this with g6 and now
let's say bishop captures queen captures
and queen g5 we want to checkmate black
this way but black will never capture
the bishop and allow pawn captures here
to allow white to have some sort of a
checkmate if queen h6 ever happens we're
just going to play bishop to f8 and
we're going to cover both the g7 square
and we're going to kick away the queen
from the h6 square so that's why that
doesn't work so we have to play bishop
captures an h7 check first and this is
with the idea of opening up the h file
uh for our rook so a nice rook lift will
be happening uh now black plays king
captures an h7 and now uh well okay uh
obviously you don't have to capture the
bishop but if you play something like
king to f8 bishop h6 is game over for
black because now it's either checkmate
or we capture this and then this is
checkmate so king king to f8 will not
work uh and king the h8 also doesn't
work
okay white has to work for his meal a
little bit but it's still completely
winning for white just bishop captures
real captures or queen captures doesn't
really matter and queen to h5 now we're
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries and there's nothing you can
do here for example rook d7
we're going to play rook to d6 and now
there's nothing you can do if the rook
is captured we can simply capture this
pawn and
rook with the pawn and now you can't
really do anything queen captures on d6
we simply play bishop to g6 check and we
continue with our attack queen h7 oh
sorry not queen h7 check bishop captures
here king to f8 and now we capture this
pawn as well
and now the black king is completely
open there are no defenses here and
we're going to very quickly win this
game
another thing after rook to d6 of course
you don't have to capture you could play
some like rook 8 to d8 but now we just
capture on e6 this is also perfectly
fine and black is getting destroyed here
if you capture the rook of course the
bishop g6 check king g8 queen h7 czech
king f8 and now queen to h8 to check
king e7 and of course queen captures and
g7 will be checked made the pawn covers
the d6 square so like we said bishop
captures an h7 this doesn't work this
doesn't work so we might as well capture
it but now we play bishop to f6 and now
it's a completely different story now
queen captures on g7 will be checkmate
if you defend with rook to g8 queen to
h5 will be checkmate because the king
will not be able to retreat to the g8
square so your only option is to capture
the bishop and after the bishop is
captured we're going to play e captures
on f6 now again threaten mate here uh
it's
the exact same thing if rook blocks then
this will be checkmate so you have to
capture on f6 and now simply rook to d3
and this is how we deliver checkmate
there's nothing black can do about this
he can play some silly moves uh like
just you know some like queen e5 to try
and interpose but it will only prolong
mate for a few moves
uh so
uh that's uh the position hope you guys
enjoyed that and the previous one i i
really enjoyed both of them and if you
guys uh
enjoy videos like these uh do mention in
the comments if you enjoy more of them
because like i said these uh positions
are much much different than the ones
that would occur uh in modern games and
maybe you can learn a little bit more on
how to think how to approach a position
how to attack not just how to attack
there are also some ideas on how to
defend how to avoid the stalemate how to
how to force stalemate you know there
are
very very enjoyable ones uh so
those were the the games hope you guys
uh enjoyed that to do share in the
comments if you would like to see more
of this
i would like to thank michael kennedy uh
constantinos from pedagogy ricardo
rodriguez
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
checking up on everything else that's
happening in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day